[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie
maximum effort this is going to be my
new deadpool
marvel x-men disney plus video there
were a couple big announcements and some
cool stuff that ryan reynolds and hugh
jackman were doing last week
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with deadpool
in the mcu really big stuff first just
starting with number five if you didn't
see what was going on recently hugh
jackman and ryan reynolds were
celebrating the anniversary of the first
x-men movie from 2000 they just started
adding the marvel x-men movies to disney
plus recently too i know a lot of you
were asking about that
to mark the occasion hugh jackman posted
this funny video of himself behind the
scenes on the first x-men movie fighting
a wolverine action figure wearing the
classic yellow costume from the comics
the joke there is that hugh jackman is
just making fun of himself from that
first movie
because when he took the job as
wolverine he didn't know how hard it
would be to get in shape to play him
and run around shirtless through most of
that movie so they had to film him in
really weird ways just to hide that he
wasn't super swole yet until the last
few weeks of filming
six months later when he had finally
gotten huge enough
as you probably remember this scene that
they were filming right here was him
escaping from the med bay after famka's
jean grey starts checking him out
so i know a lot of you were asking me
about all the disney plus account
x-men post the past week because the
disney plus social accounts
just in general were posting a ton of
x-men stuff to get everyone hyped up for
mcu marvel x-men
and x-men the animated series which is
also on disney plus right now
they just really want you to think about
x-men being on disney plus
but the bigger deal is actually all
about deadpool 3 in the deadpool
movies so hugh jackman was also posting
about himself in x-men days of future
past
to celebrate when that movie came to
disney plus last week
he's been posting a lot of x-men
wolverine stuff the past couple of weeks
and doing a couple interviews i've
already done a couple wolverine
videos on my channel about that stuff so
i'll add links in the description
but when that happened both he and ryan
reynolds went on about how it's the
first movie
of any kind not just a marvel movie to
air on disney plus
completely uncensored so the reason this
is a big deal
is because hugh jackman gets pretty
naked on screen and drops a couple
f-bombs
there's a little bit of other language
it's just that the f-bombs are usually
where disney draws the line in terms of
content on disney plus
so number four of course ryan reynolds
chiming in appropriately joining by
saying
that it's time to do the same thing for
deadpool meaning
putting the deadpool movies on disney
plus once the legacy deals expire
no matter what disney can't put movies
or tv shows on disney plus
if they're still under licensing deals
with say like netflix or other streaming
outlets and broadcasters
that's why x-men days of future past is
the only x-men movie on disney plus
right now
the other x-men movies are just stuck
under deals with other places that
haven't expired yet
but by next year most of the x-men
movies will be on there
the big question when disney was still
in the middle of buying fox last year
and getting all the x-men characters
back
was what they would do with deadpool
because he's a rated r
franchise to begin with first the disney
ceo then kevin feige the deadpool
writers
all said pretty much the same thing that
they would be allowed to continue making
rated r deadpool movies so deadpool 3
would at least at first be rated r but
when it came to disney plus it was a
little bit different the disney ceo
said last year that they had no plans to
put the deadpool movies on disney plus
because they were rated r and at the
time they wanted to keep disney plus
firmly pg-13 because at first most of
the people buying disney plus were
families with young children that wanted
that library disney content
now it's a little bit different because
they have big programming like the
marvel disney plus shows they have the
mandalorian which is blown up huge
coming into the mandalorian season two
so you have a lot of older people
middle-aged people that are now starting
to buy into disney plus finally
but last year after it launched there
were a few movies that were pg-13 on
disney plus that they still wound up
censoring language and violence out of a
little bit pg-13
isn't really that violent or gratuitous
but somehow disney still found stuff to
trim
out that all changed this past week with
x-men days of future past
100 uncensored full-on naked hugh
jackman walking through frame like it's
no big deal
dropping f-bombs all over the place in
disney's backyard and they're totally
cool with it
so three ryan reynolds is basically
saying that they found a way to
bend time and space with the infinity
gauntlet and get the deadpool movies on
disney plus eventually
even get deadpool 3 on there too when it
gets made in a couple years obviously
we're still a ways off from the making
deadpool 3.
but it's also further confirmation that
they intend on making a deadpool 3 movie
if there were any doubters that were
still out there a while ago there were a
bunch of rob liefeld twitter posts and
interviews he claimed that marvel was
never going to make deadpool 3 they had
no intention of doing it
right after ryan reynolds literally said
on national television that they were in
the middle of working on the movie
so that should be your first clue that
the movie is actually happening
ryan reynolds spent most of last year
going to meetings at marvel
starting to figure out their early work
so then marina bacharan came out a
little while ago too and said that she
hadn't really heard much about her role
in deadpool 3 because they were still in
the middle of writing the movie
so the fact that they're writing
deadpool 3 should be a clue that they're
making deadpool 3.
i think when marvel got all those
characters back last year people just
expected deadpool 3 to happen right away
which isn't the case marvel already has
the next three to five years mapped out
in terms of which movies they're doing
even though the virus kind of added a
year to that because of all the delays
there might be a few changes towards the
end of that schedule but for the most
part
all these movies in marvel phase 4 in
the marvel phase 5 schedule have been
decided
if you look at the phase 5 schedule here
which before the virus was just
2022 and 2023 the first part of marvel
phase 5 not the entire marvel phase 5.
some of these movies they still haven't
publicly announced yet but based on
other sources
these are what i think some of those are
going to be like spider-man 4
has already been confirmed by sony even
though they haven't put a date on it yet
is probably going to be happening here
the marvel reboot of fantastic four is
probably happening somewhere
in here and we just found out about
ant-man 3 and captain marvel 2.
so deadpool 3 and say like the blade
movie will also probably happen
somewhere in here too
so number two disney hasn't said
anything about when the deadpool movies
previous licensing deals are up so right
now they couldn't put them on disney
plus even if they wanted to
but the key to all of this is once upon
a deadpool
if you never saw that deadpool movie
technically it's kind of like a third
deadpool movie but it's not deadpool 3
it's just the pg-13
alternate cut of deadpool 2 with a bunch
of different scenes and footage
so it kind of feels like a different
movie especially with all the fred
savage princess bride parody scenes
there's a scene during that where
deadpool at the beginning literally
explains to fred savage
exactly what the movie is and why he's
being censored
what what the easy now hey the only
f-bomb we're using around here
is fred savage now i want you to take a
deep breath and listen to me very
carefully frederick
you're in a pg-13 version of deadpool 2
which means we only get two
one and a glass of white wine are you
bleeping yourself you bet you're voicing
a little
but right now they could literally just
slap once upon a deadpool up on disney
plus it's good to go but they'd also
have to give the same treatment the same
alternate cut
quote-unquote to the first deadpool
movie too which would take a little bit
of work
so no timeline on when that would happen
but based on ryan reynolds posts and his
jokes it sounds like they're figuring
that out right now so
number one even though deadpool 3
probably isn't gonna get released till
at least
2023 or 2024 they're still going to
release a rated r theatrical cut
initially
before they give it the once upon a
deadpool treatment the way ryan reynolds
talks about marvel and kevin feige
they're excited to do the movie but the
big issue right now the big sticking
point in terms of story
is marvel's still trying to figure out
how they're going to integrate the
deadpool character into the mcu
in whether or not all of his future
movies will be traditional mcu canon
or if they'll just treat them like the
new mutants movie new mutants is being
released by disney and marvel
eventually we should add after getting
six different release dates
maybe someday we'll get to see that
movie so the movie doesn't really
reference
any mcu stuff like avengers end game the
snap any of the infinity saga movies
and the mcu movies in the future won't
reference these characters
at least for right now the thought is
that if it's successful enough marvel
might eventually bring some of these
characters back in future
x-men related movies right now deadpool
sounds like his rated r movies like
deadpool 3
will just be their own thing they'll
make jokes about the mcu reference mcu
events like the snap avengers end game
make jokes about iron man dying like he
made jokes about wolverine dying during
deadpool 2
make spider-man jokes but you won't
actually see deadpool and spider-man
cross paths or
deadpool in the avengers together on
screen until
deadpool shows up in another pg-13
traditional mcu movie
and when he does he'll sound and feel
more like the deadpool
from once upon a deadpool let me know in
the comments though what is the first
mcu movie that you want to see deadpool
cross over with in a big way
my early prediction right now is that it
probably won't happen until avengers 5
but he could always show up anywhere i'm
hoping that they surprise us and he just
shows up somewhere unannounced
everyone click here to watch hugh
jackman break down all the marvel
wolverine movies and click here to learn
about marvel bringing thanos back
in future mcu movies thank you so much
for watching
everyone stay safe maximum effort
[Music]